alors attention on va voir on a préparé
vous allez voir ya une roue et vous
allez voir qui vous a limité à chaque
fois c'est parti
la battle d'imitation attention alors
que c'est une battle un donc philippe
lellouche doc patrick bruel contre fifi
lachaud qui va imiter van damme
c'est à elle d'imitation elle n'est pas
du tout choquée la roue ne réserve pas
de moi tu rêve depuis longtemps
il a neigé envahit l'écran vers ma fille
parce que tu peux faire patrick bruel
qui reprend une chanson de charles
aznavour
ah oui il a fait battre le pouls et
ennui au cours de deux euros
avant ce ventre alourdi de free les
bateaux est ce que tu peux faire à ce
d'amour qui me bruel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il peut le faire très attention il peut
faire bon vivre et béchir pour les plus
jeunes qui nous regardent bourvil c'est
comme fifi voilà et bachir accès comme
bamako
merci comme ça c'est dit il
van damme est à toi c'est horrible je
sais pas le faire mais oui c'est ça j'ai
déjà perdu ceni faire le grand écart
d'illimité battu le remplacer que boulou
je suis ferme en effet jonathan
pedneault pas bleu s'il fait beau il
faut changer les images
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
van damme tu peux le faire fait colonne
est même pas une phrase il en a
l'habitude non mais c'est le petit
mousse dans est ce que tu peux faire
j'ai pas compris je suis désolé là on
doit dire qu'il ya mieux fait brûler
est ce que tu peux faire beaucoup et qui
chante du patrimoine
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais je donne quand même le point s'il
avait fait très bien aussi un deuxième
hôtel deuxième battle je rappelle que la
route n'est pas truquée folie qui va à
weston a dit dan
en fait chacun seul côté de la rouquette
à quai alors on va démarrer pas vous la
wii il est passé gold royal boch bon
choix
ouais on soir à tous je serais très
heureuse d'être avec vous ce soir
spécialement vous qui abrutissent et les
enfants les adultes c'est un
abêtissement sans fin et on vous aime
pour ça merci sega la nuit vous
émissions sont magnifiques coloré avec
des invités manière vidéo
mais on parle pas de sécu et ça c'est
pas bon chantal alors ridha jenayah il
ya un passif qui tue lui a déjà fait ou
pas du tout un jour je suis trop timide
c'est pour ces panneaux solaires 110 me
dis comme ça va c'est pas moi et ma low
cost comme ça que je vais te près de
rodez et le sage livinière dans la rue
qui renaît bâtir j'ai vu avec des
enfants il ce n'est une porte
j'avais jordan mais tournant c'est peu
mais voilà ce qu'ont été les maisons à
peu perdu et et voilà mais bon c'est pas
malien est un délit et quelque chose
alors il ya une belle tentative d'ott
était belle du niveau là comme à chaque
fois que le coach est truqué ah ouais
d'accord
ah oui ah oui d'accord donc ludivine
céline dion et moi je dois faire jean
luc reichmann toi c'est pas tilté des
jeunes tâche
[Applaudissements]
shi tellement conne kahn d'être là ne
partez pas sans moi a cessé d'exister
rico
sessègnon mon frère elle est en grâce à
la bu elle a appris que tout bon sens et
lyon à pointe à pitre
[Rires]
moi ce que j'adore c'est la photo de
settat photo cyril là c'est vraiment la
photo qui aurait eu si tu faisais
d'immobilier en fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce gala et nicolas se garer vous n'avez
pas de vis-à-vis du continent il dit il
ya un énorme potentiel à cette
croissance
ce pacte à vous pouvez faire une clé ce
qui m'entoure d'imitation ah oui c'est
la question qu'on se pose la question
la question coquine
en france où blancs ont déjà fait tonne
badaboum crac crac alsace au travail et
à tort pas candidat cette arrestation il
va re sonné chantal excuse à bosser sur
l'anecdote aussi un peu valbuena qui
jouent au foot parce que c'est laid à me
qui lui chatouiller couilles c'est vrai
dire
[Applaudissements]
moi ce que je propose c'est celui-ci
vous fermez les yeux le public au soir
est juste ou pas ce sera dans les bacs
simple et banale non non il ya un truc
au fait il ne l est pas bien on ferme
les yeux la concurrence et je dois
trouver
je sais que c'est difficile peut-être on
revient là dessus on laisse du temps la
régie mais on peut pas trouver une image
de zidane qui est en train de parler à
sa place on coupe le son et la grille
chantal fait la voilà veut dire à la
sécheresse c'est pas mal ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci de ta gang est celui sur la grosse
pub haribo les hommes interviennent
trois des mutations et des bâtons j'aime
bien j'ai bien j'espère que ça va
retomber à gad elmaleh nicolas sarkozy
il doit me faire
ah ben là je sais pas si un passif on va
démarrer par toi basique a gelé jamais
fait pas il met alors à temps mais je
suis embêté parce qu'il le fait
tellement bien felipe bon temps mais il
faut le faire après je vais faire la
versa est j'ai tout à fait des trucs de
kader mais je vais faire de la casse
je vais faire la version moi le fait
d'en diriger du maroc c'est usher
enrique thomas c'est assez terrible
parce que je sais pas bien le faire il
le fait tellement de l'arête de foot
écoute je vais bientôt les nerfs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si l'as moulins c'est d'abord un plaisir
d'être ici à cette émission c'est très
bien une émission qui est que le dit
personnellement l'ouverture aux autres
je sais pas et je vais vous dire
monsieur n'à ya plein d'endroits où j'ai
pas forcément mis les pieds faire
content que venir vous voir pour deux
raisons qu elle vous nagez vous dire
c'est quand on a peur du vent monte pas
en haut de l'arbre
et là moi j'ai envie de venir dans une
émission les gens vous regardent
ouais c'est tout ça m'inspire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à travailler tu peux faire pas du tout
avec carla c'est du sérieux non ça aurai
je démarre dans les rites à sion une
expérience à ce point de montages euros
là tu vas nous faire une textes sont
telle est la trame temps partir à la
retraite à 61 ans c'est bon tu sais si
tu domines mais jamais fait non plus
[Rires]
déjà jouer les cons j'ai jamais fait un
bond et jette un thème même type que
sarkozy c est toujours comme sa bio oui
c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sugar
ouais
[Applaudissements]
l'une fait sans péter les chéris je sens
que la basse apple non mais c'est quoi
en abbas est très très fort de quoi mais
mais mais on aurait dû demander aux gens
qu'ils qui vous savez imiter fait cela
je pense que cet après midi à des gens
ton équipe qui sont venu te voir et qui
t'ont 10 mai s'ils savent pas imiter la
personne qui en veut tu as dit on s'en
fout ils vont le faire quand même merci
alors je le dis jamais on s'en fout on
arrête cyril alors passionné enfin
l'assureur dont ça tourne sans fin
d'ailleurs vous le faites chacun mais là
pardon ça tourne cette rixe à l'eau
j'écoute
en fait chacun votre meilleure imitation
par exemple que chantal ce sera zidane
voilà si c'est en dépit des doutes
alors là attention aux débats affalé le
boeuf vas-y alors je passe mon tour pour
des raisons techniques très bien
d'accord loua s'est améliorée mais tu as
à dalida abadie il venait d'avoir 18 ans
il était beau comme un enfant c'est en
fait je change pas de vous les cheveux
c'était bien les florentins sarkozy mais
l'habitation tant la plainte mais ça y
est c'est bon je sais que je suis pas
moi je sais françois tu allais faire
[Applaudissements]
nous composons la pendule de l'entrée
s'est arrêté sur medici joli jeu n'était
tragique my book
attention on m'accuse de clara morgane
vas-y à ma frange suis un père freddy
mercury je sais faire personne là c'est
pas fait du mieux que tu n'iras pas ce
que c'est
garde ta meilleure est allé à meilleur à
6,6 tanner une élève asie et ligue 1 non
mais j'ai spécialiste des méthodes qu'il
fait très bien
en outaouais et ballon fort dès que j'en
ai lu ton bien d'accord ou non et non je
vais je me suis trompé avec l'autre les
jeunes et louis meurt jamais et il
apprend qu on n'est pas rendu là il
avait préféré et li et kim raconte il
sourit il adorait cette belle série b k
et sarah sont sur un bol par toutes les
deux et permirent de la plaquer ou de
mouvements et ben se rapproche et puis
elle commence à parler de leur intimité
tu vois et voilà à bord il y en a une
qui étudie et sarah lui dis moi tu ne
parles toi à ton mari quand tu fais
l'amour tu lui parles quoi vous toi lui
dit pas quoi
eh bien ça dépend mais s'ils m'appellent
sur un portable je leur réponds
blessures
[Rires]
[Musique]
tu peux parler arabe et il a raison
gagnes tu peux pas le faire après yann
piat liste à part bravo vous coupez mais
chantal voudraient l'imiter pendant un
an je veux comprendre y gental effectif
est super bien en fait dans le privé
alors si vas-y vas-y chantage fait
travailler avoue même physiquement
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais pourquoi tout le monde ne fait
comme un singe mais c'est besson s'est
moulé pour ses blessures je me semblait
si c'est qu'on vote
[Musique]